American journalist Grant Wall and  former Wales soccer player Laura  McAllister saying security barred them  from entering in Rainbow themed clothes  supporting lgbtq rights when I asked  them why they said because it was a band  symbol and that we weren't allowed to  wear it in the stadium  and earlier in the day before facing  England Iran's players stood silently  during their national anthem a sign of  solidarity with anti-regime protesters  in their Homeland  Freedom the move came a day after team  captain essan Hajj Shafi said  we have to accept that the situation in  our country is not good and that our  people are not happy we're here but that  doesn't mean we shouldn't be their voice